you know disease i think of disease as
usually a problem of syntax
that bad language is the cause of
ill health and what you know people's
reaction to that can
range from that it's a revelation to
that they can't understand
what you're saying you know how this
could even
be but uh all these forms of
disequilibrium
have to do with how you perceive
yourself in the world
and this is linguistically mediated even
in the privacy of your own
head and you see it very much with
children
they learn uh
diseases they learn syndromes of
disequilibrium
and they can unlearn them too if they
can be deconditioned
so in that sense then i think you said
before that
having better maps will somehow decrease
our anxiety and suffering
for the future what i feel you saying
now is
it not so much that but my own feeling
is transformation of the self is what's
going to
stop the suffering no matter what form
we use it may be intuitively right to
use drugs at one moment and to swim at
another
that's history is full of examples of
near-death experiences and sexual
experiences that have
open windows that's absolutely correct
intuitive
private matter at that level it's a
totally public matter at another level
and just what level do you want to talk
the self is the central modality
to be dealt with i mean that's what i
mean when i say
you can't accept ideology imposed from
above
or it will create neurosis we must each
realize how important the self
is that it is in fact ultimately
important and then try and create a
uh a personality a self image
and a society that's based on that and
we have been
robbed of our experience you know and
even in
earlier cultures about which we may feel
very ambiguous like let's say
the the peak of medieval christianity
which has certainly had dubious aspects
about it
nevertheless the stress on
self-examination prayer
uh being straight with yourself about
where you were vis-a-vis the commission
of evil acts
these interiorized states uh
throw you back upon the self in the way
that these pre-packaged ideologies
do not i often think you know
i was raised catholic and my children
have nothing to do with that i won't let
it near them
but i often wonder what they're missing
being ages
three and six uh by not walking around
thinking about sanctifying grace and the
eight beatitudes and
whether or not they have sinned against
the fifth
fourth sixth and ninth commandments and
because this was my interior world as a
six-year-old
and you know after making a good
confession i would
search for the sanctifying grace that i
knew must now
be mine and it was a state of
interiorized self-examination that for
though
that may have been wrong-headed in many
ways the central notion
that you are responsible for yourself
is very important to retain all these
shaman are responsible for themselves
that's what they really are they are
responsible people and once you have it
it's hard to lose and once they take it
away from you it's very hard to
recreate this is why you know
we are all you know some of us may feel
that our lives are not as satisfying as
we wish or we are not as
realized as we wish but we must
represent
uh you know the upper
0.001 people on earth
locked in these kinds of concerns
most people it never is an issue they
are
so locked in the modalities dictated
from above
that they never realized that they are
alive or that
they had any opportunity that could come
from within
and this is a tragedy i mean i am
not a reincarnationist i take life very
seriously this may be the only
crack you ever get at immortality
so to blunder it away by accepting
pre-packaged ideologies and that sort of
thing
there can't be any greater tragedy than
that
we all have an obligation to create a
language that values
us and the people around us and this
begins with a language that values the
cell
and our experiences experience this is
the central thing above and beyond all
else
[Music]
you